this is what's left of alchemy hospital
in a blip province we were at home with
our kids when a Russian warplane carried
out an aerial raid against a hospital
and also a residential area people are
fed up with life here we don't know
where to go no one can help no one can
protect us from these attacks many of
the patients here have been injured and
evacuated to other hospitals dozens of
medical facilities have been destroyed
in airstrikes in recent months staff
here say these facilities were attacked
deliberately I work in the hospital it
was directly targeted the hospital is
not operating now and it's completely
destroyed due to the direct shelling so
many were killed in dozens wounded the
Syrian civil defense group known as the
white helmets also blames Russian
warplanes for the attack the Russian
warplanes targeted al shami Hospital and
the surrounding residential areas in
areia in three air raids our civil
defense units rushed to the scene and
were trying to evacuate a woman and a
boy under the rubble Russia is
supporting Syrian government forces and
has denied bombing area hospital Moscow
insists it avoids attacking civilian
targets Turkey's president red ship Type
O Dewan says both Russia and Syria have
violated a ceasefire in in lib brokered
by Turkey and Russia earlier this month
the territory is the last that's
controlled by rebel groups in Syria's
northwest region thousands of civilians
are caught up in the violence the UN
says more than 350,000 have been forced
to leave their home since the beginning
of December many families are now
packing their belongings and leaving the
city of area but they don't know where
they can go that's safe Victoria gate
and B al Jazeera